I heard JD's not doing any butts now
he's ruined the whole time now listen
after last year I said I'm not doing any
more bets I don't know what I I knew
this I knew this would come again uh and
I bet with a lunatic over here who did
like I don't do it Part of Me wishes I
want to be uh fun and be free Like
Richard and Sal anywhere else but does
not do well sure I would love to be able
then why not try it you've never tried
it's not there's too much in my head and
it's not gonna happen do a straight up
bed if you win Richard blows you if uh
you lose you blow Richard how's that
okay I said I would kiss Ronnie I'm not
Mickey I'm not gonna I don't want a
tongue kiss I'm not gonna tongue kiss
him
you're not gonna have a choice once
Ronnie grabs your head he's stabbing
that tongue right down here well that's
his bro that's his issue I you know
what are you gonna do will play harder
if you bet this bet yeah here's the BET
then this is it
whoever loses puts on a dress and
lipstick and a wig and makes out with
Ronnie that's it Richard like that
no no no it's going to be weird I don't
like that yeah it's gonna be really
weird
[Laughter]
Ronnie's scared of my breath and my
teeth though yeah you stink man but yeah
[__] what do you say It's gotta be for
what is it 15 seconds it's not like yeah
you got to give Ronnie some time to work
his magic yeah man come on if I'm gonna
do this I'm going to do it right give
Ronnie time to get us hard dude I don't
want to pressure Anthony JD if you don't
want to make the bed listen he was the
one who brought it up yeah I know kiss
you well this is what it's for address
I'm trying to do something a wig and
this and that I'll tell you what if it
makes you feel better we'll do it
Officer and a Gentleman style Ronnie
will wear a military outfit
that's the problem the Bengals have won
three in a row against the Chiefs I'm
waiting it's this is the story of uh of
a Cincinnati Fan's life uh you're just
waiting for the other shoe to drop and
you know all the hell to go you know
whatever what does Ronnie get out of the
bed but a boyfriend I mean that's all
he's yeah
I don't know how he still agree I know
one of us might have to marry Ronnie too
I feel bad for Ronnie making out with
you Richard Jesus Christ
Ronnie's gonna be rooting for the Chiefs
because he wants to make out with JD
Ronnie what bet did you lose
all right you know what I don't know
it's up to you guys let me know later in
the show what you want to do with JD
that's the bad if people
in this [__] conversation whatever
we'll do whatever all right all right
impression
[Music]